guardians of the galaxy - time - your  brother is directing it yes you notice  is he a little bit more laid-back on the  second one or a little bit yeah I mean  he's always pretty laid-back on Sat  anyway but I think that I think that the  pressure has has subsided a great deal  for the second movie it's not you know  people aren't aren't worried that it's  going to be the big bomb you know um and  ya know that was a great project I'm  very excited for for people to see that  yeah you cheese with the Ravagers are up  to this time around I can just say that  the Ravagers are they have have a nice  nice role in the second film that they  um they're starting to get a little  testy with with yondu and there's a  little discontent brewing among the  Ravagers  you